[Music]
i saw you on tmz yesterday they asked
you guys both which of you is funnier
and you were very gentlemanly you jumped
up very quickly to say chelsea's funnier
oh but that's the truth though she is
okay well i i i submit to you
that comedy is very subjective so that's
a matter of opinion some people are
going to think you're funnier
yeah well obviously steve you [ __ ] do
because you're bringing this up
but what is not subjective is numbers so
which one of you is richer
yeah we have to we have to bring it we
have to compare our bank account yeah
yeah i've done that yet every new
relationship so we really haven't done
that kind of we don't have spreadsheet
information yet
if you were to believe celebrity net
worth stuff which is just so like
hilariously wrong like 98 of the time
then chelsea is is considerably more
wealthy but okay this is where we went
from jokes to
hey then
this is steve steven's like i know who's
funnier it's the person with the most
money
well i mean but joe i think they're
super light on you man i think that
they've really grossly underestimated
you they
they haven't seen where you're going if
you're comparing the size of venues that
you guys are going to on tour then joe's
got it by a mile
yeah he is playing bigger venues that's
for sure yeah he is and that's why he's
working this weekend so he can start
saving money so he can have as much as i
do
for that big comparison yeah
no i got to say
i think i'm visibly blushing i'm
embarrassed for having put you guys
through that it's called stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole and if you go on
amazon and type in stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole and order yourself a
bottle you'd be really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon and if you buy a bottle
we might go up the ladder and that would
mean a lot so please get on amazon and
buy stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
yeah
yeah dude